Okay so, we're going to have a quick quiz. Michael insists on having
one, because Michael likes that sort of thing, and I like Michael,
so I'm going to go with him and give you a quick quiz
to see if you follow along with what we talked about. Now this
quiz is less about the details of mimic itself. Than it is
about the probability distribution. So I've been harping on this idea that mimic
doesn't care about your probability distribution. You should just pick the best
one. So we want to make certain that you get that by giving your
three problems and three probability distributions you might use and see if you
can tell us which one goes with which. Okay? So here are the three problems. The
first problem is you're fitness function is maximize the number of 1.
So the first thing you need to, to see is that; we're going to assume in all of
these cases, that our input value is x binary strings
of length N. Okay? So, 00000001001011. 11100111, whatever. There's going
to be a string of 100. So, they're binary digits.
And the first problem we want to maximize the number of
1s that appear in that sample. Do you get that, Michael.
>> Yeah. I mean it's, I mean that's going to
be maximized by just making everything a 1, right?
>> That's right. That's right.
>> Okay, but, but we want, we want to think about mimic finding
that. Right, because you don't know
that, that's the true underlying fitness function.
That just happens to be what it is.
>> I see. Okay.
>> Okay. So, in the second problem, we
want you to maximize the number of alternations between
bits. So, 101 01 01 is better than all
1s, much better the all 1s in fact. because
the fitness you'd get from maximizing alternations. Between
01 0101 is in fact, N minus 1 which
is the largest that could be. But if you
add all the digits being the same, your fitness
would be 0. You see that Michael?
>> And minus 1, oh, I see and
minus 1 because it switch every time it switches.
>> Right.
>> Got it.
>> So what would maximize the number
of alternations and say, hey. Five digit string.
>> Like 01010.
>> Or?
>> The compliment of that, 10101.
>> Right. So two values both act as maxima here. Okay.
The third problem is you want to minimize two color errors
in a graph. Now that one is a little bit
harder to describe, so I'm going to draw a little graph
for you. So, the two color problem you might remember
is given a graph with some edges, like say, this graph
here. You want to assign a color to each node
such that every node has a different color than its
neighbor. Okay? So, we assume there's only two colors here.
One is zero. So let's say I assign This the color,
value of 1. This the color value of zero. This the color value of zero.
This the color value of 1. And this the color
value of 1. So how many errors are there? Michael.
>> Wait, we're, oh, we should be trying to maximize. But, okay,
so I guess not. So minimize two color errors. So an error would,
in this case would be, an edge that has the same color on
both ends. And I see one of those, the bottom sort of rightish.
>> Right. So here these do not match. So that's good. These
do not match. These do not match. But these two match. Even though
that one doesn't. So there's exactly one error. So in these first two examples
we're trying to maximize the fitness. Here
we're trying to minimize the cost just
to make things. Slightly more difficult for you. If we removed this edge here,
then you'll notice that this has no
mismatches whatsoever, and this would be an optimum.
>> Got it.
>> Okay? So we need to figure this out. Okay? So there
we go. To maximize the number of ones in your string or maximize
the alternations by adjacent bits. Or to minimize
the number of two color errors in a graph.
Alright. Those are the three problems. Now here
are the three distributions. The first distribution, these are
in alphabetical order, is a chain. So a
chain would be in kind of Bayesian network speak,
a chain would be a graph. Like this.
Where basically every feature depends on its previous neighbor.
So, in a four-bit string, I'm saying that the first
bit depends on nothing, the second bit depends on the value
of the first bit, the third bit depends on the
value of the second bit and the fourth bit depends on
the value of the third bit. So, the way you
would generate samples is you would generate a sample from here.
And then generate a sample on here dependent upon this value.
Given that value, you generate a sample here. Given that value,
then you generate a sample given that value. Got it Michael?
>> I think so. So, and, and we are imagining that the
ordering is given. So, that, so, we know which ones depend on which.
>> Right. So, in fact, it's not just a chain. It's a specific chain.
>> And is it the same chain as, say, the ordering of the bits?
>> Yes. In this particular case, it's the same chain as the
ordering of the bits so, I'm going to call this that chain.
>> [LAUGH] Alright.
>> Okay. The second one is what we've been talking
all about along. It's a dependency tree. Unlike in the case with
this chain here where. I am giving you a specific chain. This is
the first bit, the second bit, the third bit, the fourth bit
and so on to the nth bit. I don't know which is the
dependency tree is or you have to find it but there is
some dependency tree I want you to represent. And the third one is
the easiest to think about and
that's where everything is independent of everything
else. So, if I were to draw that. It would be a bunch
of nodes with no edges between them, directed or otherwise.
And so, the joint probability across all your features is
just a product of the unconditional probabilities. So, the simplest
probability distribution you can have. Okay, You got that, Michael?
>> Yeah, so. And, okay, if I'm understanding correctly,
each of these is representable by a dependency tree.
>> Yeah, each one is, actually. So then why, why would
any one be better than any other one?
>> I don't know, Michael, you tell me?
>> I guess in the case of, well could be, you could think of
it maybe in the terms of number of parameters that need to be estimated. So
in the independent case, since we know
that it's independent or at least we're imagining
it's independent, we just have to estimate
one probability per node, which is like N.
>> Yep. In the chain case, we have a
conditional probability per node. So it's, like 2n parameters.
>> Mm-hm, yep.
>> And
in the dependency tree case, it's. I think what you were saying is that
we're estimating kind of n squared parameters. And
then, then pulling the tree out of that.
Exactly. Now, of course, like you point
out Michael. A chain is a dependency tree.
Independents are a dependency tree and a
dependency tree is surprisingly enough a dependency tree.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But these numbers and parameters do matter, because
although a dependency tree can represent and independent set
of variables. The way your going to discover that
their independent is that your going to need a
lot of data to estimate those in square
parameters in order to realize that the conditional
probability tables effectively don't mean anything. So, it
will be very easy for a dependency tree
to over fit in the case where all
the variables or all the features are independent. Okay.
>> Okay. Alright. So, you got it?
>> Alright. Nope. One more question.
>> Yes?
>> Well,
other then I need to fill the boxes with the numbers one, two, or three, right?
>> Yep. Of the algorithm that they're best for,
or the the problem that they're the best for.
>> Got it. And each one is used exactly once? Yes.
>> Okay, and then finally just to kind of
make sure that I am wrapped head around why we
are doing probability distributions at all. So in the
context of mimic, we need some way of capturing the,
I guess the space of answers that do at least a certain level. They,
they do at least this will and [UNKNOWN] the fitness. So, it, it, it.
>> Hm.
>> I guess, I guess I feel a little
turn off because. We're not trying to represent the
fitness functions, right? You're not telling me which dependency
structure should I be using to represent this fitness function.
>> Right. Instead I'm asking you to figure out which
distribution will represent the optima,
the structure between the optimal values.
>> Huh, okay. Alright, I'm not sure I 100% get it,
but I think I get it enough to answer this quiz.
>> Excellent. Okay, so go.